[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une image justement des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui passent
aujourd'hui une sorte de grand oral
devant les responsables du medef et les
patrons je vous admire plus encore quand
je vois les conditions économiques dans
lesquels vous travaillez sourire
d'ailleurs de circonstance à la tribune
regarder marine le pen a laissé sa place
à eric zemmour après lui avoir
brièvement serré la main n'oubliez pas
de la classe politique des niveaux de la
classe journalistique
parce que si l'information du jour c'est
elle a serré la main d'eric zemmour si
vous n'êtes pas au niveau de ce qui est
en train de se passer dans le pays je
vous dis gentiment suis je crois la
seule candidate qui a l'audace de dire
qu'il va falloir dépenser moins et
travailler plus
nous sommes des êtres civilisés nous
nous servons la main
ça me paraît assez normal on n'est pas
dans la cour d'école vous savez dans
quelle république sommes nous pour que
je sois privée de mes parrainages alors
que je suis la principale opposante à
emmanuel macron et que les sondages me
donne aux portes de la victoire pour
mesdames et messieurs les maires j'ai
besoin de vous dans ma propre
circonscription aucun avait parrainé
aucun en disant je t ai lu sur étiquette
aujourd'hui on en met une j'aurais beau
expliquer que j'ai parrainé untel ou
untel juste pour que le débat
démocratique ait lieu les électeurs ne
comprendront pas donc c'est un je me
mets à la place du maire compte aussi se
retrouver tricard j'aime bien ce terme
trika par rapport aux subventions par
rapport aux ailes de local qu'on peut
avoir moi j'ai une petite commune et
j'ai besoin de quelques aides du
département de la région et
effectivement je pourrais m'atteindre
peut-être à des représailles parrainer
ne s'est pas soutenir et que voilà et
que chaque candidat qui représente un
vrai courant de pensée dans la société
doit pouvoir avoir les parrainages pour
pouvoir se présenter c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé de parrainer le candidat dont je
suis le plus éloigné puisque je suis
classé à droite si jean luc mélenchon je
combats ardemment ses convictions ses
idées ses valeurs mais il doit pouvoir
concourir c'est exactement ce que je
plaide si rigolo parce que au début
n'était pas de cet avis mais c'est mais
c'est très bien les évolutions sombres
sont bonnes
vous allez marine et qui met une
signature ne suffit pas de toute façon
monsieur bayrou était là et allait de
toute façon alors faire la courte
échelle 1 parce que justement là en
l'occurrence on parle quand même de
candidats qui sont présélectionnés en
quelque sorte mais de quoi il se mêle je
vais pas lui de s'en mêler elle sait pas
eu de deux ans plus de fixer les
barrières à 10% face et profondément
choquants et même à la limite conséquent
ciel devrait rod ok des gens comme ça
c'est pas normal quoi j'ai toujours
considéré l'extrême droite comme une
menace pour la république une menace des
millions de français sont prêts à voter
pour eux des millions de français en
soute nippon tard quand il a pris le
pouvoir en 40 jean lassalle
dans les compteurs du conseil
constitutionnel donc bah ouais
non ce qu'il avait déjà fait la dernière
fois est une sorte y rencontre continue
tant mieux pour nous parce que c'est une
menace pour la république je serai
intransigeant en pleine campagne
électorale
fabien roussel sous le feu des soupçons
le candidat du parti communiste at il
réellement rempli ses fonctions
d'attaché parlementaire j'ai travaillé
dur pour ce député e le grand comme on
l'appelle dans le douaisis que je
respecte beaucoup et bien j'ai fournir
un travail avec lui tout au long de ces
cinq ans des parts affirme en effet que
fabien roussel aurait occupé un emploi
fictif d'assistants parlementaires entre
2009 et 2014 sans avoir réellement
travaillé je me sent attaquée parce que
j'ai fait un travail de fond c'est comme
si on attaquait tout lé combat qu'on a
mené c'est comme si on attaquait cette
classe ouvrière qui s'est battu avec
sincérité tension maximale ce soir cela
crise je craignais vladimir poutine doit
prendre la parole à la télévision il
pouvait reconnaître l'indépendance des
régions séparatistes pro-russes de l'est
de l'ukraine